so this is fun I want to talk about
relationships a little bit relationships
I'm not the best in relationships
nothing serious it's just like I have a
tendency to be what I call a dad
boyfriend do you know I'm talking about
it's not as gross as it sounds oh I'm
not dating my dad hey wait up you want
to go the Red Sox game just touched oh
that was my father it means that when
you kind of play a dad role in your
girlfriend's life whether that's what
they wanted or not you kind of treat her
like a toddler and she's not she's not a
toddler I've never dated a toddler I
can't stress that enough
I've never dated a toddler but as I
could toddler you do a lot of baby I do
a lot of baby talk as a dad boy she's a
checking account she knows when she's
hungers she's a grown woman she
has a real estate license she flies
alone you remember she's grown but for
some reason it's hard for dad boyfriends
like me to remember that like when I
when I have a girlfriend and she stays
over for the sexing of a lifetime and
she gets up before I do and she showers
I will actually keep an ear out listen
to this I'll keep an ear out to make
sure she doesn't slip and fall I know
that's kind of crazy and kind of sweet
but that's dawn dad toy dad toy dad
boyfriend
we'll be right back just kidding
I will lay in bed and make sure she's
safe while she's doing something she
literally does every day like in the bed
like a lame pajama Superman
listening for a disruption in the water
because that means she's moving I'm like
oh okay yeah it's not it's not steady
flow she's in she's in there oh it's
that weird sound when you wash your butt
that's good she said it always gives it
away washing my ass everyone knows
everyone knows and if I don't hear those
hilarious sounds I just jump right just
straight to worst-case scenario I'm
picturing in there one leg behind their
head like water going into her open
mouth I feel you backing away but guess
what she's fine she's totally fine why
cuz she's 28 she knows how to shower she
wasn't raised by wolves and even if she
was you could pretty much explain that
very quickly to someone who was raised
by wolves like this knob right here
that's like when wolf mother would lick
you clean don't slip and ladies here's
how you can tell if you have a dad
boyfriend it's often in the way he holds
your hand what is it's a cher song if
you're laughing you're 30 secure guys
they'll be happy with just a pinkie just
flirting with the idea of a handhold
walking down the street like you just
met the Queen of England like on Shantay
dad boyfriend's they're all in it they
hold your hand like they don't trust you
near traffic you hold hands with a dad
boyfriend for two minutes your hand
looks like you got red from touching a
stone understand holding up for your
friends like are you okay yeah Brian
just loves being a weird way but it goes
the other way too listen this some guys
I know have mother girlfriends I've had
mother girlfriends myself just like a
girl in her 20s that's still like
remember no hoagies today and walk the
dog pal okay what you wanted them you we
agreed you would walk professor freckles
Walker
come and do your chores or no BUTT STUFF
alright mister here's where it's
creepier though guys sometimes like it I
know so many guys that are into their
mommy girlfriends they own it sitting on
the couch just like sweetie sweetums
could you make me a sandwich make
yourself a sandwich you Freudian
nightmare you're a grown man you should
be embarrassed to have another fully
formed human being bringing you a Sammie
with the crusts cut off just like a like
or these sweet pick is your salad
pickies I don't like the song Vicki's
sour pinkies taste angry you're a
district manager you have 13 people
working under you she's playing your
xbox she brings it to you on your
favorite plate really thanks mom I mean
thanks babe
[Applause]
[Music]